quelqu'un peut faire un flop
[Musique]
d'autres
ça va très vite
[Musique]
soit se protéger
tenons bien fait la deuxième c'est
comment on peut tomber
[Musique]
mais pour moi j'espère que personne je
dors ici
et si je joue tout les cas pourquoi je
prépare juste s'en excuse moi
tu vois qui a dit ça je passais aristote
encore
[Musique]
[Rires]
si les faire une chanson facile facile
de là le vent souffle sur la plaine
armoricaine
hakim le fils du forgeron est venu me
chercher
c'est pour une expérience se font
maintenant c'est
aller continue ces gens si tant de
secondes six gérants l'hydrothérapie
aller continue
voilà ça les deux heures forcément
débat meilleure équipe et c'est vraiment
très sincère vraiment vécu comme ça je
ne veux t'en occuper le site envoyer
notre chef opérateur
bien il a sa façon très particulière
d'aller chercher les bâches
tutu j'ai quand même de la mise en scène
d'un âge
[Musique]
il ya des vaches la brède
on les rajoutera en 3d en post prod
c'est les colas majesté
kaunas est super et kaunas super sympa
pour être plus clair et sortir du
comique de répétition là tu ne vas pas
le tout en un
[Musique]
et du côlon darrouman aller de gauche et
de droite
[Musique]
non mais vous êtes posséder on va pas
manger ça ben ça mais j'en ai 4 ap
monjeza faudrait 4 ap
juste une dernière
le cherche on est là bas un barrage
pourquoi pour le casser après c'est
marrant et c'est pas possible en fait
mais c'est pas possible en fait
mais c'est pas possible en fait ma job
[Rires]
c'est pour nous une expérience sociale
retrouvera en ligne et
il est plus élevé que la moyenne c'est
tout non non
quand vous voulez
j'en ai entendu tellement que
maintenance en brune fonds propre
comédie
t'es sérieux selon toi
[Musique]
c'est pas possible et nuls écoutent oui
oui comme ça va chercher la boule et
relance
[Musique]
parce que il n'ya rien de mieux pour un
réseau social que des bâtis autour de
saucisses qui se solidifie sensiblement
à la chaleur de ceux ci
arrière arrière arrière arrière vient
des rangs derrière arrivé
[Musique]
à moi
ne l'ont dit luce j'ai pas lui même
générique
[Musique]
[Rires]
attend attend bien voir bien voir ça lui
sert il mieux je suis le producteur de
l'émission merci d'avoir regardé ce
super bêtisier mais est maintenant qu'il
est fini je suis actuellement en ce
crime sur nantwich donc tu peux venir ça
va être sympa on va faire un quiz autour
de cette saison d'été on va vous
expliquer un petit peu le contexte dans
lequel elle a été faite et c'est un peu
particulier ça va être intéressant on va
pouvoir parler vulgarisation général
peut être appelée de trois copains on
verra bien en tout cas bien on va être
bien c'est sympa reid myope pièce